hey guys happy beta it's the vlog every
day in August a lot of stuff has
happened in August if you're new here I
got a puppy I'm about to take puppy's
poop sample to the vet and we're gonna
take our first car ride by ourself this
is gonna be something something fun but
you're real sleepy so oh you're so cute
we're gonna put you in the bag I'm sorry
you okay little guy okay it's okay
you're doing so good jennife on her way
to come see little baby Maddy big big
big big big I have known at Starbucks in
before I got him why cuz I don't love
the house I think this is officially
what motherhood is not going to
Starbucks every day I'm a little
concerned than what I actually have to
start leaving the house and getting back
to work as they would say I need to get
him super trained and supervised a you
to travel be a good set companion you're
probably ain't been s time to be able to
take a shower and then she was like and
later it pooped on me again oh my god
I'm so tired I don't think I could never
have children this is this is confirms
let's confirm that I think children in
my future I can barely take care of
myself
like why does it go here break your mat
okay turn around
look over here don't drink the dole
that's look around look over here Matt
he's a belt he's right over there come
on Matt your hair especially this door
finally letting you adventure into the
grass a little look I just love him oh
that means poop Oh a spin he's doing the
poop spin spin
he's he's gonna poo go get a treat ready
go get a treat ready good boy ahh
it's solid it's a solid pool it's your
first so much this is your theme song I
have such a proud puppy moment puppy
mommy moment today who's your first
solid first solid poo
holy moly we need each one you pee pad -
oh my gosh
you should go into your cage now I think
he's going cage he's gotta learn get in
there go to cage go to cage such a good
boy oh I love you so much we gotta put
you in there honey we gotta put you in
okay just a minute so you already surety
puedan peed so I know you don't have to
do either one of those so right now
there are three mats in the house man on
that you guys match look at you you like
me look you he's got a nice little white
outfit it's you you like your mat and
there's mat and there's mat should we
get both okay do you wanna come over
three mats
how many mats wears one not two not
three but he's like I don't know what
the heck is going on I just want to go
although what the hell is this is this
snail where did this come from
oh okay I don't I don't do well with
bugs I'm just gonna say like it's
creeping me out and I don't like it
he's gonna be so many friends coming
friends
here look Maddie this is the home you're
gonna tell me to go pee oh here Maddie
right here what is that no boy oh all
right cool
so we are about to put on Maddie's first
outfit do you want to do you want after
what you guys home can you actually form
clothes yeah you can pick from camo or
camo which one you want but a big did
you did
you're gonna pee on my thank you like
okay let's this is gonna be way too big
you need to like start getting jacked up
wait this is an extra extra small okay
honey let's he's tired you don't want to
dress up right there's a left all day
you stop all day I know you have worms
but let's put your head here
oh so he is so fit look I feel like we
were just doing this to little bow we
were you coming to me for safety again
[Laughter]
breathing yes he's breathing
he likes the burner okay do you want to
give me his prison
let's give me his prison oh here we go
let's give Matt his pregnant what it's
something
matching mad outfits that's amazing so a
question for myself and for everyone
here is this how people hang out look at
this it's just too precious
okay so we're also we're doing some some
ANOVA maneuvering I'll say some mono
roving maneuvers Jana's gonna bring this
into the kitchen it's out of focus but
you guys get the point
sure bring your back oh those new looks
nice okay I'll push it back then are you
doing a first dry yeah hold on wait let
me take this into the kitchen first how
much you weigh yeah you're good hold on
hold on hold on hold on I just stand up
what do you think you like it was slow
you I feel like I just played your
floors yeah they're not clean well
they're clean now I just on that you not
not the dog
forget the dog I'll say it's no no is
this a good idea okay all right all
right
wait I'm gonna go I'm gonna follow you
this is a good song though good you got
those [__] all ready go yeah all right
oh my gosh this is happening right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
my [__] might hit bone nobody my life is
like yelling it's not bad
oh no I'm just not filming no somebody
sit down we're not gonna sit now imma
walk this one off
I've never steered my eyes are now
you're good we're fine I'm laughing
cause like I don't know what else to do
oh my gosh
[Music]